thank you very much we're going to
Austin Texas Apple is opening up a
fantastic facility they're spending a
tremendous amount of money and I've been
asking Tim Cook from the day I got
elected from the campaign I've been
asking Tim Cook to if they would we want
to see a flow built here that way you
have no tariffs it's not terrible when
companies come to our country and they
build
there's no tariffs the economy is doing
unbelievably well we continue to talk to
China China wants to make a deal the
question is do I want to make a deal
because I like what's happening right
now
we're taking in billions and billions of
dollars I'm going to go very quickly
just a quick comment on what's going on
in terms of testimony with ambassador
Sandlin and I just noticed one thing and
I would say that means it's all over
what do you want from Ukraine yes please
screaming what do you want from Ukraine
I keep hearing all these different ideas
and theories this is ambassador
Donnellan making the main this happened
to which I turned off the television
what do you want from Ukraine I keep
hearing all these different ideas and
theories what do you want what do you
want it was a very short and abrupt
conversation that he had with bin
they said he was not in a good mood I'm
always in a good mood I don't know what
that is he just said now he's talking
about what my response so he's going
what do you want what do you want I hear
all these theories what do you want
right and now here's my response that he
gave just game ready yep the cameras
rolling I want nothing that's what I
want from Ukraine that's what I said
I want nothing I said it twice
so he goes he asked me the question what
do you want they keep hearing all these
things what do you want he finally gets
me I don't know him very well I have not
spoken to him much this is not a man I
know well seems like a nice guy though
but I don't know well he was with other
candidates he actually supported of the
candidate not me
payment late but here's my response now
if you weren't fake news you cover it
properly I say to the ambassador's
response
I want nothing I want nothing I want no
quid pro quo tell Jelinski president
delicious to do the right thing so
here's my answer
I want nothing I want nothing I want no
quid pro quo tells the lynching to do
the right thing then he says this is the
final word from the President of the
United States
I want nothing thank you folks have a
good time we're going to fester
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you